I am many, many hours late today.
Catching up on admin stuff.
Wrote a draft of my new article.
made a few changes to the website.
Few other miscellaneous things I've been
meaning to catch up on.
I figured I'd get a short research
stream in though.
Short research stream.
The main thing that I really want to do
today is just to go over
uh I just want to go over some
experiments.
I want to queue up some new ones.
I want to think about a few things.
Nothing particularly difficult.
Nothing super intensive today.
Just want to see if we're in the right
direction or not.
So,
We don't get any policies that solve.
That's quite bizarre.
new business offerings.
And uh one other thing,
prelib sponsor.
We should have done that a long time
ago.
Oh, we get to support that project a
little now.
Okay. So, this is the other one here.
This one is much more concerning, right?
Yeah. This one's much more concerning
that this doesn't solve. Something is
wrong. This is not pong. This is
breakout.
I know you can definitely solve this in
like 5 mil.
So something went
wrong either with the sweep or
something, right?
Let me think how we even consider this.
Right.
This one is a bit more concerning, I
think.
Hello, Jess.
Just a little bit of checking
experiments and trying to draw some
conclusions and launch some new ones.
Jeff, short stream today.
been doing on other things.
I do have a draft of the new article,
personal article, not technical article,
but
got some cool stuff.
This is kind of weird that this does
this
How could this happen
that it doesn't solve?
Just super out there.
Did I sweep network sizes when I did
this before?
Let me see if I can find the uh the runs
I did with breakout before. That might
give us a little bit of insight.
What? Oh, there it goes. Okay, so this
is like nearly
this is nearly a solve, right?
This gold on.
Only two of them here.
Hello bet.
Welcome.
Why does this have 28 mil agent steps?
That hardly seems right.
That could just be EV's, right? Could
very well just be evils. One frame skip.
Yeah, it's totally evs. We'll double
check that, but it should totally just
be eels.
Uh, this is actually with
this is with a different architecture,
isn't it?
H.
Yes, they are.
Did I somehow just miss This
Did that not go?
Oh, yeah. It didn't go because that's
fine. So, let's do this.
Uh,
four blocks.
Okay, so apparently this was just I set
it to a block,
so not a huge deal.
So, did I just not sweep the hidden size
at all? Is that what I'm seeing here?
Yeah, I think I just set the hidden size
up
and then I got this like 5 mill
solveish.
I mean, I could try that, right? There
could just be some weirdy thing with uh
a weird thing with sweeps.
That shouldn't be too difficult to
verify, right?
that like sweeping the uh model size
somehow screws stuff up.
I mean, this is what I was using before
anyways, not Pong, right?
So, we have the most data on this.
Yeah. I mean, we have, look at all this,
right?
It's 20 mil with no frame skip, right?
So if we give it 40, that's the
equivalent of 10 mil. It should
definitely be able to solve something,
right?
I think I fixed the time steps. Maybe
at least I did on I think I did on the
second one. I fixed it to 20
20 mil,
right? Because this prevents me from
having to do anything with sample f at
all. Right.
Oh, you know, that's probably why um
Yeah, that's got to totally be why this
didn't work before, right? I probably
messed it up with the max cost
shenanigans.
Okay. Well, I mean, I can work with
this, right?
Just wake myself up a little bit.
Oops. Let me answer.
Let me double act. Let me actually check
to see if I made the exact error. I
think I did just so I don't jump to
conclusions.
I'm pretty sure I did.
I've been meaning to do that for a
while.
Oops. Not this right. We go to here. We
go to here.
So what I did here, let me explain the
error I made. I have this max cost
filtering that prevents you from taking
suggestions that are above the max
budget. But I forgot that I had the cost
in seconds and then I did over samples.
I was just filtering all the
suggestions. So of course I screwed up
my experiments. I must have just been
tired.
Make that mistake. It's funny I even
caught it now on the next day, but that
was just dumb.
Uh, we'll just do
one E7 is 10 mil.
I can do like this. Yeah,
max cost of 30 seconds still.
And we're just going to rerun it. In
fact, I'm even going to leave the uh the
old ones alone.
then we'll see if this does anything
different. Yeah.
One also has a max cost. I bet you I did
the exact same thing.
See, this is the like the reason that it
it almost doesn't pay to do research
tired. Like it's almost better to just
not do research tired because you make
mistakes, right? And then you start
making like conclusions off of bad data.
Like it's so much more valuable for me
to get a couple good hours than it is to
get like 10 bad hours.
cuz 10 bad hours are going to create me
like hours of additional work.
I don't necessarily have a good solution
for this.
Uh, this one seems like it was actually
decent.
It looks like I actually kind of did
this one correctly.
Okay, we'll have to play with this. Let
me just make absolutely sure I didn't
just do something even still dumb on
this.
Times is uptime. Steps is agent steps.
Costs equals
Oh, wait.
This is what I just changed, right? I
changed this to times.
I change it.
Yeah. No, I did it right.
Hey, Kvert.
Yes, I can get you a box. I got to see
if who replied on what boxes they're
using. Let me just double check this and
then I'll find you a box. One second.
You know, I just edited nothing.
This is in sweep.
Okay.
So, wait. What the heck then? Did I just
Bet. Do you know who's on what box?
I can get a convert a
Okay. I could have sworn I'd done that
differently.
No one responded.
Uh Aaron's not using stuff.
convert. DM me your email and I'm going
to DM you. Um,
uh, there's a one pager that you have to
sign.
uh that says that you will not do bad
things with my machines
and I can get you access.
It's literally like a onepage dog. It
just says you're not going to do bad
[ __ ] on my machines.
So, just on Discord, DM me. Email.
Just on Discord, DM me. DM me your
email. Um,
I'll drop you a doc in there as well to
sign in a second.
Okay, this is actually going to throw me
for a loop now because
now I don't know why this is not working
correctly.
I did allow for sweeping of hidden size.
Let's try a sanity thingy here.
We're going to just ignore this.
Yes. It means you have bad juju forever.
You'll never escape your fate.
So, some of these runs,
3 minutes, 4 minutes,
we're going to give it 240 seconds
per run.
Nice beefy budget.
Get a hidden size
Let me go get you your dock.
I don't have a DM from you yet, though,
I don't think. Unless I missed your
request
Oh, all those DMs you sent me before I
didn't get because Discord doesn't have
a notification system that works.
But yeah, you can get some compute.
Hang on, let me go find the dock.
Send this in a while.
I'm sure you did with all the [ __ ] that
I answer on a daily basis.
The hell is this thing
legal?
Buffer cluster. Yes. Buffer user
agreement.
What is this stupid thing?
I hate this dumb thing. those. Why do I
have this crap operating system?
sign this in blood. Add a couple of your
own hairs and then uh send it to me by
carrier pigeon.
Ideally express carrier pigeon.
full feature requested for Ray Lib. I
actually don't even have any specific
feature requests. Um, I might in the
future, but this was kind of just long
this was kind of just long overdue.
I mean, we use Ray Lib for so much stuff
and the guy makes like nowhere near what
he should off of this project.
I mean with as much cool like look the
way I run Puffer it's like I have to
hate money for the way that I run Puffer
right this guy really has to hate money
for the way that he runs Rayb with how
awesome what he's built is
physically sign digital's fine
long as it's real name
it can't be convert from Discord.
This is the point is that I have a
document that says you will not do bad
things on my cluster.
I have one for
everybody else in there.
Let's see if we've gotten any. Whoops.
That's
I'm seriously hoping that this fatigue
gets better as soon as I start eating
again.
I assume it probably will, right?
I mean, I currently have a calorie
deficit that's more than most women's
daily calor uh calorie intake.
it's honestly it's not the only thing is
the fatigue.
It's basically just the fatigue. That's
it.
Everything else is kind of just fine.
This is the last week of it as well, so
this is as bad as it gets.
And I thought it was going to be rough
today, but actually the strength was
just fine. Still haven't lost any
strength.
That's the article as well. I wrote up
um an article on this whole thing.
It's like a longer story as well, which
I've told pieces of on the stream
before, right?
I am probably going to post um pictures
of this as well cuz I'm very proud of uh
I'm very proud of this training block.
Like literally I look in the mirror and
I go, "Holy hell, I've never looked that
good in my life."
Image classification in PO. Oh, I only
really know of CNN's. So, you don't ever
really want to do RL when you can do
supervised learning, right? Supervised
learning is a stronger signal than RL.
You do RL when you can't solve your task
with supervised learning.
That make sense?
The reason RL is like awesome is because
we can solve all sorts of stuff that we
can't solve with supervised learning.
Not because you know it's better than
supervised learning when you can do it.
H
I'm trying to think what the heck this
could have possibly
been.
Well, hang on. Did I just
Let me just check I do this correctly.
I just did.
Oh, you dummy. Why you do this?
40 mil, right?
40 million time step.
I could try. Do I try the same thing
with Pong?
I forget if I already did.
Uh,
it's worth a shot, isn't it? If I just
fix to 10 mil.
You fix 10 mil.
Max cost.
when you've signed that
um
you may go ahead and send that over and
I will get you
Bet you're not supposed to do this.
Okay.
If Rayson tweets it, then he tweets it.
But just like flexing the sponsorship
like this on Twitter is kind of like
like have a little class, man. Come on.
It's one thing to talk about the thing
on stream.
I figured I'd wait for race on to do it
if he wants to.
oh, it's cuz it's followed. But look,
there's literally Why is there not an
option to say like show me less or
whatever if it's an account I follow?
algorithm
I'd be so much happier if I could just
get rid of X, but it's kind of where all
the open source and business stuff comes
from, so I tolerate it.
He posted it in Discord announcements,
Rayb.
Awesome.
I like open source because it like it's
like a funnel for people who just care
about really doing cool tech and get
into one space, right?
Like my goal is for Puffer to go like
more and more hardcore technical over
time, right? with still being accessible
more than it is to just like I don't
know, you know, be a big thing but not
actually push Frontier.
Four and five are idle. Okay, cool. So
yeah, you can use stuff then convert on
that if as soon as you
as soon as you send me the blood oath.
Uh, no. What's going to happen, Bet, is
in a few weeks I'm going to go to
Maryland and set it up and then you get
to use it for as long as you want.
Believe me, as soon as basically as soon
as I'm done with this week, I've
finished my training block and then I
don't really have much more reason to be
here. So, I'm going to finish up stuff
and uh attempt to get myself back to
Maryland.
I've got all sorts of fun new equipment
there. I've got a new training block I'm
pretty excited to start.
I mean, I really don't want to give up
the cardio shape I'm in, but
I don't know how the hell to maintain
the cardio shape I'm in while starting a
new training block as well.
That's the thing that just sucks so much
about cardio, right? If I get like if I
put on muscle or put on strength, it's
way easier to maintain that than cardio.
Cardio is just like, yeah, you're going
to do the same program. You're going to
do it six days a week or it's going to
suck.
real life training will RL training.
Yeah, exactly. What do I I do
reinforcement learning all day either on
agents or on myself.
I'm really proud of this training block.
This is definitely not the hardest thing
I've done, right? Like the 50k training
block was harder,
but like the results of this are really
Nice.
It's also amusing to me because it's
like
in some ways like it's more psychotic
than the 50k training block. The thing
that made the 50k training block really
just like way hard, right? is you have a
really long run once a week and that
long run just beats the hell out of you
and it's like the it's like
at least half of the value of the
training is in that one long run a week.
But this was more just like beat me up
about the same amount every single day
with no reprieve
cycling best cardio.
The problem is it's dangerous as hell on
the roads.
Um, and it's completely boring on a
stationary.
Honestly, the best cardio sport if you
have a pool is just swimming.
It's like by far the best thing.
I guess I could get into that. I've
never liked it is the thing. I could try
that again properly, though.
To be fair, I have not tried swimming
since um like I'm way better built for
it now than I ever was before.
Yeah, I always I hate water getting in
my ears
more than anything. They're
I mean, regardless, like,
you know, you're going at high speeds on
a bike, on a road.
I mean, I get tired enough when I'm
running to borderline like crash into
stationary objects. I definitely would
not want to be that tired on a bike.
If I'm going casually then like, okay,
fine. Right.
This is starting to fill this chunk in,
but it's not doing well.
I guess the question is like why?
I know that this thing can be made.
Well, I definitely know this thing
should be way better than this. Maybe
this is the question I should ask is how
the hell did this do so poorly?
Oh, you know what? I gave it 182nd
budget.
I gave it 180 second budget on a slower
chip.
That's probably it right there, right?
Yeah. But with the large batch training
might just take longer,
Okay, if we assume that's the case,
what about pawn?
Okay. I mean, we'll find out from this,
I guess,
cuz I gave Pong more budget this time.
So I guess fundamentally then the
question
the question remains of how we're going
to evaluate the the whole frontier,
Well,
okay. The dumbest thing I could do,
right? Okay. The dumbest thing I could
do,
I could just have
I could do fixed time step sampling,
right?
That actually if I do that well enough
that will solve it.
If I just run this sweep at each like
time step increment and let's say keep
the models around. Okay, that will work.
That's really stupid, but that's
guaranteed to work.
I don't know why I didn't think of that
before.
No, not DT per step. Basically like
if I want to calculate the data compute
frontier, just run the sweep for each
amount of data that I want to consider.
And if I keep the Gaussian process
around between those runs, then it
shouldn't take all that many samples to
figure it out.
Invert, I'm getting dinner in 40. Do
sign this dock if you can.
Um
maybe sooner depending. I'm kind of well
had a super late breakfast today. I
think I'll be good until 6.
Like this morning instead of getting up
and going for my run immediately, I got
up and worked on my article for three or
four hours.
Kind of just felt like that.
Okay, I mean this was one very good
insight out of this.
So now really all I have to do is I have
to figure out.
Let me run the multi sweep code on
Puffer Max. We'll do that.
When's the cut ending?
How do I measure weeks? It's th It's
this week. I'm trying to think if I
count I probably count this Sunday.
I probably count the end of the week as
Sunday instead of uh Saturday.
I mean, as you can see, I've gotten some
like I've gotten some cool stuff in the
last couple weeks, right? This is not
the type of work where it helps me to
even be focused for 12 hours, right?
This is like very experiment dependent
work where I just have to like set
things up correctly.
I kind of planned everything so that it
would like be pretty set overall.
Inverse been trying to figure it out on
Linux.
I honestly I wouldn't be surprised. It's
I forget. I think it's it's either
Firefox or Chrome. One of the browsers
has just a built-in signing tool.
I'm going to switch this to my camera
for a second so I don't accidentally
open this on stream.
Good thing I did that. It immediately
opens it on screen on stream.
I have never seen anybody do a signature
that way, but that'll have to do.
That's so funny.
That's a total Linuxism. He took a
picture of his signature and pasted the
picture into this the signature box.
Hang on. Let me put this into my drive
and I'll bring the screen back over.
I understand you Linux things. Honestly,
getting back to my Linux desktop is also
going to improve productivity because I
won't be able to open league.
Okay. Uh,
make sure I have this closed and I will
bring the screen back.
What DRO do you use anyways? Normally
just Abuntu.
I had my whole tryh hard arch phase but
vanilla Abuntu.
with Libra. Oh jeez.
So in undergrad, actually I still have
this. Let me show you what I used
throughout my whole undergrad.
old surface
with freaking arch on it with like
shitty carbon fiber textured not really
a case on it
with some shitty custom sticker I had
made plus some random ass internship
sticker I had. I ran Arch in a VM on
this thing
with like crazy custom i3 rice to hell
and I had a desktop a customuilt
like dual SLI water cooled like openloop
desktop that I had in my room
the whole time.
I had a freaking like outdoor
outdoor strobe light that I kept in my
room
and uh I wore my hair about five times
this long and tied it back with a
bandana and wore like flannel lumberjack
looking shirts
and I got my kicks trying to convince
people I was from Texas.
I had some hilariously dumb blunder
years.
Uh, right. You're you wanted an invite
for this, right? You've given me your
blood signature. Now I need to give you
an invite.
Let me do that.
Tell me what plugins you use for Neovm.
Better yet, I can just give you my
config.
It's in uh the puffer container.
It's in the puffer container cuz I use
it.
Oh, I no that actually that's the thing.
Uh I knew exactly what I was doing. I
was intentionally doing like the
stupidest [ __ ] I could think of because
I just like never done stupid [ __ ] in my
life and I wanted to try just being dumb
about everything for kicks.
Where is the thing? Okay, right here.
Here's my config. There you go.
And the thing is even at that time right
like for being 19 20 I think even like
18 19 like I was already a pretty damn
good researcher for uh being that young
like you know I was publishing while I
was doing that crap.
So I was chilling.
Now, I wasn't publishing anything good,
but I did publish.
I beat like some other things that were
being published at the time.
Oh, yeah. That's the other fun thing. I
probably weighed 135 that whole time.
I don't even want to go dig up those
pictures.
Okay, Kinvert.
Uh, one moment.
[Music]
You will have an invite in your inbox.
I will put you on five. I think four or
five.
There you go. And uh I think the
container on there is dated, so you can
feel free to put a new one on it. You
should have perms for I think you should
have perms for everything container
related. Not for host machine stuff, but
for whatever container crap you want to
do.
Right. So, the one other thing I wanted
to do is I wanted to try to get like a
sanity repro on
uh I wanted to see if I could get some
sort of sanity repro on puffer max.
See if I can do that.
Oh, I should actually check what this
was, right?
Basic pong F.
Okay,
so this is the one thing I am actually
proud of.
Um, I got through
undergradu
uh in California without touching
anything but alcohol.
Probably had too much of that, but
that's all I touched.
I wish I could have told myself that uh
drinking is a habit that takes a couple
years longer than you would expect to
kick,
but other than that, I think I made out
pretty good.
All right, this is the other thing I
wanted to check. So,
This is why I have my own version now
cuz this thing is so stupid and slow.
Oh, this is where I did a stupid, right?
Yeah. Yeah. This is where I totally did
stupid.
incredibly stupid
Total epoch.
The heck.
Apparently, this somehow only got
triggered at the end.
I don't know if it's you don't think as
hard honestly.
There is actually like a certain clarity
to it.
if it's you don't overthink necessarily.
Hello there.
I have no moral opposition to any
substances, right? It's just that they
are all [ __ ] horrible for you.
Hell, I mean, if we could make if we
could make alcohol and say steroids that
didn't kill you, that would be amazing.
Like, you'd have to be a [ __ ] not to go
for that stuff, right?
I don't know. For some reason, like
there's this tendency to monkeys paw
everything where it's like everything
that's fun and enjoyable has to be bad
for you for some reason. But like that's
it's just not true, right?
Yeah. The thing that put me off uh
marijuana was I had I had a roommate my
freshman year who did nothing but smoke
and he was just like
just like the dumbest trashiest guy I'd
ever met.
back.
Yeah. It's also, from what I've heard,
one of the hardest habits to kick.
So,
I think I'm good on that.
Honestly, easiest thing ever um to quit
drinking like without even really
trying.
Grab literally anything other than
water.
Like literally half of it is just being
used to drinking something that isn't
water.
So, coffee is great except you can't
drink coffee all day. That will mess you
up just as badly.
Total epoch. That's got to be zero,
right?
It's way worse than ruining your sleep.
Take it from a guy who was on like four
cans of Monster a day in undergrad.
Honestly, caffeine's probably done more
than me than anything else.
Messes up. I mean, it's anxiety. It's
sleep. It's digestion. It messes up a
lot of stuff.
Just don't It's fine. is don't drink
freaking six plus cups of coffee.
I have like I don't know two three cups
a day now most of the time.
it was pretty funny cuz in undergrad I
could literally just cut weight or gain
weight by switching from uh you know
lowal to full sugar like in back and
forth. There's literally 800 calories of
sugar from monster a day at one point.
Terrible.
Like one real meal and then four cans of
Monster and Ramen.
I do not advise that for the record.
Let the record state I do not advise
that at all.
[Music]
So, we'll see what the heck this does.
We've got this new one running.
If you have four of them, you'll get
screwed up with or without the sher. I
guarantee
All right. So, one useful experiment
launched, one useful insight.
Uh,
I increase mass cost. I mean, we can see
if this does anything, right?
You'd think it should.
What did I do with this? I think I did
do like fix 10 millie.
I have officially reached grumpy old man
status that the thing I'm most looking
forward to in uh Maryland is not having
to listen to the neighbors kids
screaming anymore.
Get off my lawn.
Well, this will work, right?
I think that this run is fine.
I did remember on this one to take out,
right? I Yeah, I took this one. Okay,
this is fine then. So,
do we not have any like new data at 40
though?
40 mil. 40 mil is like down here, isn't
it?
I don't see. Why didn't I see data
forming here? Did I mess it up?
Huh?
Why is it doing this?
Wait, why does it have shitty scores
this like this low?
Or seven.
Yeah.
I don't know. I have like a
I have like a very strong attachment to
peace and quiet.
Like gentle rustle of the wind and bird
song and nothing else is ideal.
I I
in tech and in science like there's just
there's already so much noise and
distractions and stuff like the most
important thing in my my mind for
research and for progress in general is
mental clarity.
the best thing you can do is just
eliminate anything
that distracts you
or you know it's like you really just
need to be in a state of like you know
being constantly engaged in kind of like
a relaxed and generally good mood and
just kind of like slowly piecing through
and thinking through things at like a
sufficient remove
the whole sort of landscape of
everything.
No,
I've always thought meditation's kind of
just [ __ ]
My version of this is I put on an audio
book, I go run, and I go deadlift.
Walking a few hours is good as well.
I'd do that, but then I would have uh no
time left in the day. I already spend a
good couple hours on exercise.
Yeah, Jess, it's just it's too San
Francisco for my liking, you know.
it's not necessarily what you're aiming
for
cuz that's when you're making like good
progress on work that's like not at the
cutting edge, right? I do that when I'm
working on like a new simulation that I
roughly know how to build, but it's
engaging enough to be interesting.
Research is never that basically, right?
Cuz research is
it's like constant reframing and
rethinking.
There's very very little work that's
like, you know, I know what to do, just
do it.
That's why it's so hard. Like I can
never put in the same number of hours on
pure research.
Um as I can on like other tasks, right?
Go for a walk in the woods. Yeah. See,
that's way better in my mind. That's way
better.
What could have possibly gone wrong
here?
it simply be that the chip is slower?
Doesn't make sense, right?
Something is so screwy with this. Well,
it is six.
Hopefully the pong run at least does
something.
super hopeful, but we'll see. And
definitely we should get
Horizontal sampling. What?
What?
Okay, here's something.
Uh, what the hell's going on with this?
Yeah, this is not supposed to be what's
happening.
Let's fix this and then I'm going to go
get dinner.
Yeah, this is not remotely what should
happen, right?
12 E7.
Oh, you're just dumb, right?
Just 12v6.
Yeah, I'm just dumb. Okay.
Fun.
All right, I'll probably take another
quick look at this after dinner.
Hopefully this produces something,
though.
Let me see if there's any uh we did
anything.
thank you for tuning in, folks. Just
quick research stream today.
Over the rest of the week,
I'm just going to keep working on little
bits of research here and there.
The goal is to get us to a point where
we have fast sweeps that optimize um
that optimize for a single cost
which is just wall clock and do that
across performance. And if I can do this
well and if I can get this to work so it
optimizes at low samples and at high
samples effectively, I'm going to be
able to put something together nicely
that gives us a compute data trade-off
curve. And if I can do that across a
bunch of environments, we'll be able to
do all our large scale analysis. Really,
this week is mostly just trying to get
initial stuff set up for that.
If you're new around here, I'm an RL
researcher. I stream all my development.
I build Puffer Lib. If you're interested
in my work generally, puffer.ai.
Go to the GitHub. It's free. It helps me
out a ton. You want to get involved,
join the Discord. There are lots of
helpful people people in here. And other
than that, you can follow me on X for
all of my articles and content around
RL. Thanks. And I'm going to get some
food.